I if you went and pulled the people at a
micro Brewery about who their political
uh who their political affiliations are
who do you think that would be
it may not have a political opinion but
it knows that it's better than you at
the very least that's the one thing that
I thought she said that was correct beer
should not have a political party I
don't need every single product that I
get to have a political party attached
to it but what Budweiser just did was
the dumbest thing I've ever done or ever
seen I've never seen a company shoot
themselves in both feet so quickly well
I I would agree with you maybe two years
ago but now I'm like no I demand all of
my products just come out right now and
say Trump 2024 and fly American flags
that's it if if a company comes out and
they're selling flip-flops and they got
American flags I'm buying them because
I'm at a point where I'm sick of people
like Whoopi Goldberg I'm sick of what
Anheuser-Busch did if Anheuser-Busch
just said I don't know or care here's
beer I bet well it is what it is but
they decided to get involved and then
they apparently they give more money to
Republicans